[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood
volume 1
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon iii
is reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the show is also the
key in the history of house targaryen
the dance of the dragons
the targaryen civil war the dance of the
dragons was the most devastating war in
the history of the seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
targaryens fought targaryens brothers
fought brothers
dragons fought the dragons most of
westeros waged war in neither support of
queen rhaenyra and became known as the
blacks
or in support of her rival king aegon ii
and became known as the greens
and by the time it was over dozens of
thousands were dead
most of the dragons were killed as well
as most of the targaryens
the biggest supporter of king aegon the
second and the man who fought the most
for the greens as well as burned the
most of westeros in this war was king
aegon's brother
eamonn prince eamon targaryen also known
as aemond one eye or aemond
the king's lair was a prince of the
targaryen dynasty who wrote the most
powerful dragon of its time
mighty vagar vagar was a she dragon of
house targaryen
she was ridden by queen wizenya
targaryen during aegon's conquest
alongside aegon the conqueror's valerian
and their sister rhaenys's marxist
prince seaman and his dragon bogar
played a major role in the targaryen
civil war
by the time of the dance of the dragon
swagar was the hardened
survivor of a hundred battles had grown
almost as large as valerian
and was the oldest and largest of
dragons investors
her roar was so powerful that it could
shake the very foundations of storm's
end
no living dragon could match her for
size or ferocity
born in 110 ac aymond was the second son
of king viserys the first targaryen
and queen ellis and hightower and the
brother of king aegon the second
targaryen
at birth aemond was said to be half the
size his older brother aegon had been
although he was twice as fierce the
birds of aemon that his brother aegon
were the cause of some strife at the
court of viserys the first
the king had named rhaenyra his only
surviving child by his first marriage
his official heir in 105 ac but refused
to change the order of succession after
the birth of two healthy sons
this eventually led to the rise of
queen's party at the royal court
as opposed to the princess's party in
128 st when eamonn was 10 years old
his brother-in-law sir lane or valerian
died
amen accompanied his parents and
siblings to driftmark
to attend layner's funeral king viserys
had suggested traveling to dragonstone
after the funeral and informed eamond
who out of all the siblings was the only
one yet without a dragon of his own
that he could claim a dragon egg or
hatchling on dragonstone for his own
if he was bold enough annoyed by his
father's comment
aemond resolved to claim vegar the
oldest and largest living dragon
who had recently become riderless with
the death of lena valerian
vegard was present on driftmark and a
man who knew that his parents would not
allow him near the dragon
went to make his attempt in secret
aemond was caught by his three-year-old
nephew prince joffrey
in an attempt to keeping quiet eamonn
slapped and threatened the younger boy
before shoving him into a pile of dragon
droppings
when joffrey began to yell aymond
climbed on top of regards back
the dragon broke free over chains and
daemon flew two circles before landing
joffrey however had alarmed his two
older siblings
jacaryus and lucerus valerian the four
boys fought with wooden training swords
until aemond called his nephews strong's
as it was rumored they were
bastards of their mothers lovers or
harming strong
having their rumored father's appearance
rather than valyrian appearance of house
targaryen or valerian
jakaris old enough to understand the
insult attacked eamonn again
when eamonn gained the upper hand and
began to beat jakarta savagely
losers drew his dagger and slashed that
daemon's face
taking out his right eye after the
incident queen ellison called for
luceries to lose deny his penance
which king viserys refused while
princess rhaenyra demanded that eamonn
was
questioned sharply until he revealed
where he heard her sons being described
as throngs
as naming them such was suggesting they
were bastards
and therefore rhaenyra was guilty of
high treason by sleeping with sir harvey
strong
forced by his father amon eventually
admitted hearing the name from his
brother prince aegon
while he was an unforgiving person amen
would later say that he considered
losing an
eye to be a fair trade in an exchange
for obtaining the great rogar
afterward he often put a smooth sapphire
as a full sigh
in his empty socket despite the loss of
his eye
aemond went on to become one of the most
fearsome swordsmen in all of westeros
as he spent next 10 years being trained
by sir christian cole
lord commander of the kingsguard on the
first day of 127 ac
king viserys held a feast to celebrate
the return of his health
after the king had left the feast eamon
toasted his three valerian cousins
speaking of their appearance mocking
them as three strong boys
eamonn wore knight black armor chased
with gold
in 129 a7 aemond was 19 years old
his father king viserys the first
targaryen died
eamon's older brother was crowned king
egg on the second targaryen
despite their older sister rhaenyra
having been viserys has chosen heir
starting the war of succession known as
the dance of the dragons
at the beginning of the war eamonn flew
the guard to storm's end
to win the loyalty of lord boris
baratheon by betting one of his
daughters
rhaenyra's second son luis results
arrived on his dragon racks
with the same goal of winning over the
baratheons
lost risk however only asked boros to
join rhaenyra for the sake of his past
oaths
and said he could not vet one of his
daughters because he was already
betrothed
so borah spurned his offer when eamonn
threatened lucery stating he owed him an
eye boros refused to love them to fight
under his roof
boris's manners trained daemond allowing
glossaries to leave the hole
and take off on his drag on the wrecks
boris's daughter mary's taunted aymond
asking him if lucerus had removed his
balls as well as his eye
aemond became enraged when he asked
boris's leave
boris told aemond that he had no say
about what aemond
did while not underneath boris's roof
and allowed him to depart
aymond mounted vegar and pursued his
cousin
avenging the loss of his eye by killing
loose tourists and the racks
mushroom claims eamonn located the boy's
corpse
and removed both of his eyes to present
them to lady marys
on a bed of seaweed eamon was known the
raptor as a kingslayer among his enemies
his own mother alison hightower and
grandfather otto heitaver were horrified
by eamonn's actions they'd still hoped
the war might be ended diplomatically
but by killing one of her sons aymond
had ensured rhaenyra would fight to the
bitter end
otto haitover famously told him you only
lost one eye how could you be so blind
and then vegard's next major fight was
in the battle of rook's nest
varagon the second's armies set a trap
for reigning targaryen
riding the dragon miley's when she
arrived she was ambushed two-on-one by
aegon the second riding sunfire
and aemond on vagar even so miles was a
large dragon
and did not go down without a fight at
the end of their fall to the ground
vegar was relatively unharmed
but sunfire was crippled and nearly
killed aegon ii himself was burned over
half of his body
leaving him semi-conscious for the next
full year
as he slowly recovered in his stead at
alison's behest
eamonn stepped up to become prince
regent and protector of the realm
as prince regent aemond gathered an army
together with sir kristen cole
the hand of the king now in command
eamon demonstrated that as a swordsman
and a dragon rider he was a deadly
opponent
but also a hothead with no sense of
strategy
he decided that the real threat was not
rhaenyra on dragonstone to the east
but the main armies of her supporters
messing under his uncle daemon and
harrenhal
therefore he let out all of fagon the
second remaining armies in the
crownlands north to attack herohole
leaving the capital city with only a
skeleton defense
daemon however had planned on this and
simply abandoned harrenhal
his army moving to the west where he
destroyed the lannister's armies
meanwhile daemon himself flew his dragon
to king's landing
very near a small fleet in the east
augmented by dragons was able to capture
the lightly defended city
there was no siege as the city watch
were loyal to daemon
and supported daemon as soon as he
appeared he made his niece and wife
rhaenyra the queen of the seven kingdoms
aemond arrived at harehole to find an
empty castle and quickly heard the news
of the loss of king's landing
as well as destruction of their forces
in the west
aymond was driven into such a rage at
his failure that he nearly killed the
messenger who brought the news
in petty revenge he then used vegard to
burn every wooden structure in harehole
the second time the castle was blasted
by a dragonflame
eamon then impetuously abandoned his
main army to launch a one man one dragon
war against rhaenyra's followers
in the riverlands burning out entire
towns and personally destroying vast
swaths of territory
with him he took his bed mate the seer
alice rivers
while devastating even this proved to be
folly the army he had taken north to
harrenhal was left to retreat south
through the riverlands
with no dragon to defend it rhaenyra's
forces in the region managed to loop
around from defeating the lannisters
and surround cole's army outnumbered
three to one aegon the second remaining
army was wiped out in a decisive battle
and cole himself killed daemon hunted
long for aemond and vegard
but eamonn would flee ahead of him and
other searchers
he knew that vegard could kill any
dragon in a one-on-one fight
and his hit and run attacks would draw
out two or three of rhaenyra's other
dragons
from other fronts in the war as they
hunted him in vain
eventually despairing of the war daemon
waited alone with his dragon characters
in the ruins of heronhole
as a challenge to eamonn knowing that
eamonn would only face
him in a one-on-one fight he thought he
could win because his dragon was the
oldest and biggest of the remaining
dragons
being almost the size of balerion but he
was wrong as demons dragon was just as
fierce and battle proven
amen could never dare to duel daemon one
on one with a sword on foot
as daemon was the best warrior in his
time period and eamonn
knew it but aemond had another advantage
vegar but not even that was enough to
beat daemon
after 13 days eamonn arrived along with
a pregnant alice
she stayed on the ground as eamond and
damon took to the air for the final
mighty duel between vegar and charaxes
in aemon's final exchange with his uncle
damon he said to him you have lived too
long
uncle and damon replied on that much we
agree
it was an aerial duel that took place in
the skies above harehole and the god's
eye
between two of the most powerful living
dragons swagar and charaxes
and the writers prince aymond and prince
daemon targaryen
the duel was said to be a sight to sea
the sun was setting as the two dragons
took to the sky
so bright was the dragonfire that small
folk feared the sky was aflame
when characters attacked vogar she
ripped upon his stomach
and tore one of his wings but then
characters fast and his jaws around her
throat in a death grip
these injuries forced them both to cease
flying as they tumbled to the water
below
daemon dueled amend to death at the
climax of the fight as he never fastened
his saddle
daemon stood up on characters and leaped
at daemon
whereupon he drove his dark sister
through aemon's eye
and through his neck just a second
before hitting the water
eamon's body that was still chained to
the saddle went underwater
along with vagar was only recovered
years after the war
with dark sister still impaled through
his call
the battle above the god's eye ended in
the deaths of both riders and both the
dragons
aymond was 20 years old when he died
daemon was 49 when he died
unlike heyman's body however demons was
never found
singers say that daemon lived to spend
the rest of his days in secret with
nettles
but most historians disagree what
happened to eamon's child with
alice as well as with alice herself
remains yet to be seen
aemond is definitely going to be one of
the most important characters in the
upcoming prequel show
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comment section down below
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one peace